the Super Bowl winning head coach of the
Pittsburgh Steelers and of course of CBS
Bill Cowher back here on the show how
are you bill doing great rich I'm good
great call last night that I was
surprising I thought but hey I chose the
bills man I chose the bills before the
game l teeth thought the Jets were the
better team even though the Bills had
won five of their first seven and the
Jets they just hit him in the mouth get
him in the mouth bill they didn't you
know it's funny that you said you you
almost look like a little bit of
blueprint went against Tyrod Taylor you
know you rush five take away all of the
lanes for him because you kind of like
Russell Wilson he's more dangerous
outside the pocket than in it and you
know I think giving Calvin Benjamin's
coffee something's going to help him
down the road because right now it's not
really a receiver it really scares you
so I'm interesting to see where they go
from here but it was impressive game by
the New York Jets games I think we
stayed true that they had to win so who
is the best team in the AFC right now
you've got three teams sitting there at
6 and 2 in the Patriots and the Steelers
and the Chiefs who do you who do you
like the most out of that trio yeah well
you know I think if you look at the most
complete team right now I think you know
you look at the team that statistically
they're not playing well essentially it
is Pittsburgh I say Pittsburgh because I
think right now I'm more impressed with
what they're doing defensively I think
that Keith Butler has those guys flying
around or going with a blitz package
that can be mminton sand you know this
will pick up standpoint and and the
speed that they have right now and
they're healthy you look at it right now
I think on the offensive side the
offensive line is healthy levy on Bell
Antonio would then and it had some some
some red zone woes and finishing drives
but if you look at right now based on
health and the most balanced team I
think it's Pittsburgh Steelers so what
do you make of Roethlisberger's prior to
the plate playing season comments that
he doesn't know if he wants to keep
playing much longer or at all and then
his flippant remark tore after their
last loss that maybe I don't have it
anymore where do you fall on reading
those tea leaves
you know what in my opinion rich Ben has
always been a guy that likes to have be
uncomfortable you know I you know you
accomplished some of the things you've
accomplished you have a team you have
going in you don't come out exactly and
start performing the way you'd like to
because point they haven't consistently
but you know I think he's the type of
guy that likes to be uncomfortable at
times and sometimes you can create that
uncomfortability I mean he he likes to
have a little bit of an edge he can
create it um as he's done and I think he
plays there like that you know whether
it be whether it be an injury whether it
be dissatisfied with some degree of
anything he goes into a game and you
know if he's saying he's feeling good
and feels great I always used to worry
when he went into a game and something
was wasn't right he was complaining
about something I said he's right where
he needs to be that's unbelievable that
a coach would like like if he's like hey
I'm feeling great you're like I would
try to step on his toes or something I
needed to kick him in the shin just like
I didn't want to feel too good
Bill Cowher of CBS joining me here let's
talk about Bill O'Brien in the week that
he has had it was one week ago today
where DeAndre Hopkins reportedly walked
out of practice because of the comments
that were attributed to owner Bob McNair
in an ESPN piece about the kneeling and
social issues and social justice
that the players are fighting for and
then he gets him all on a plane after a
team meeting where the owner apparently
his apology fell flat
they still ball out almost beat Seattle
but lose and then deshaun Watson after
that game blows his knee out and
practice I mean that's all that's I just
described you a week's worth of Bill
O'Brien's week what is he thinking right
now do you think I mean that's this
unless this is let's not forget the
first week of the season you're dealing
with a hurricane he makes a decision
after 1/2 to pull his starting
quarterback and I've done that before as
well but you know I just think what Bill
has done is I mean I think he's you know
he defines resiliency I mean he
you know I love what he did in terms of
starting to build an offense around the
skill set of the Shawn Watson and he did
that and you know they've overcome the
loss of JJ Watt you know they've
overcome Marcella Whitney and so I mean
they have overcome a lot of injuries but
the one thing that bill does is he
adapts and injustice and well just and
he done it with a system on offense I
think I'll have to do it again with Tom
savage and you know and I just heard
this I yesterday when I was asked and
when I said you know the one thing you
don't forget about it he's got a night
guy named Braxton Miller if you want to
keep some that same stuff that you're
doing he's a guy I could put that same
skill set a guy that you know played
quarterback in college and we're having
Antwaan Randle well we had Hines Ward
Pittsburgh you know when you acquire
those type of players which I always
thought it gave us flexibility it gave
us versatility it gave us a lot of
different things we can do because we've
always had some clay makers and you know
so I would be surprised to see a package
and I know unless you're sure you can do
on the short week but you know right now
you look like that division they still
are gonna be a team to be talked about
you see what not gonna be playing next
year leaders you see the struggles of
Blake bortles and Marcus Mariota is a
team that that they're gonna have to be
able to beat and I think right now it
became the clear favorite met division
so outside of Jacksonville Jackson was
playing phenomenal defense obviously can
looking getting to Houston a weak one
but I think if I'm Bill O'Brien I'm
saying listen this isn't baton savages
about everybody else picking up their
game and I think he has to be
resourceful and be creative I think we
look on that team I think he's already
proven that he can be that kind of
creative and innovative guy and now the
packers bill are coming off of a bye
week taking on the Lions and it's gonna
be Brett Hundley again and when Aaron
Rodgers went down and the media was
asking Mike McCarthy about maybe picking
up Colin Kaepernick or another
quarterback he really bristled and he's
like the quarterback room is the way the
quarterback room is and and he was
adamant then we find out that the
Packers were trying to beat the Patriots
out on Brian Hoyer
so what do you think that that means for
what McCarthy thinks of his quarterback
situation
well I mean I think he needs experience
you know I think when you look at honey
you're talking about a young player
doesn't have not played a lot of games
you're looking at a veteran team that
that he is leading and so I don't know
if you can ever have enough leadership
and veteran leadership from that
standpoint and you know you look at
Brian Hoyer he probably knows the system
he understands the system one of those
quarterbacks when you look at that he's
I think he's the perfect backup who can
come in and probably very serviceable
and one or you know two or three games
stretch very smart it'll be great for
the young quarterbacks in the room so
you know again those guys are really are
invaluable and I'm sure he's looking at
his football team as you know this he's
got a good team and you know and
unfortunately Aaron Rodgers was a huge
huge part of that so trying to fill that
void it is not gonna be just one guys
can take a number of guys and maybe you
can change it from his philosophy in
terms of maybe run the ball a little bit
more now with calmly and play-action and
blocking things up and so again I think
for all coaches you lose these key guys
and injuries it's about your ability to
adapt create be innovative and in
general just what you're doing because
you know the games don't slow down and
the goals stay the same so yes it's next
man up but why that burden also goes on
the coach should be a little bit more
creative they'll always appreciate
chatting with you and calling it to the
show look forward to having you down the
line for the rest of the season thanks
for calling in any time that's for more
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the
doesn't show up